[Music]
Rihanna assigned a bright like a diamond
during her Super Bowl halftime
performance and some might even say she
was glowing because ET has confirmed the
Superstar is pregnant with baby number
two the Super Bowl is one of the biggest
stages in the world the singer debuted
her baby bump while performing her first
song better have my money
[Applause]
then she rubbed that belly while
performing her 2012 hit diamonds
[Music]
it's an Entertainer's dream to be on a
stage like that but it's nerve-wracking
you want to get it right you know
everybody's watching
and they're rooting for you ahead of her
show-stopping performance ET had eyes on
Riri and that baby bump backstage
[Music]
Rihanna and her Beau ASAP Rocky are
already proud parents to a son born last
May I would like to ask who is Rihanna
living for oh
are you kidding my son
my son my son my son my son everything
matters now uh you you you really start
to take a lot into account you know like
skydiving might go on the background for
now you know what I'm saying like you
really think about stuff like that right
it's like it's not it's not worth it
yeah just before hitting the Super Bowl
stage Rihanna heavily hinted to Nate
Burleson that there would be a surprise
guest during her performance people want
to know are there any surprises because
you know we like to see a little
something that my Shockers now I'm not
I'm not saying you have to tell us right
now right because it wouldn't be a
surprise true uh can you just answer
this will there be a surprise I meant to
say what if this surprises that there's
no surprises but after no one joined
Rihanna on her floating stage we can
safely say baby number two was said
surprise
foreign